In the
first two years of World War II the Allies
were stunned by the speed, coordination and
efficacy of German’s armoured divisions,
seemingly unstoppable.
It was the success of the Blitzkrieg tactics,
the ‘lightning war’.
This success was attributed to the leadership
and military genius of today’s protagonist.
Even before the war, his published works had
brought him to the attention of military leaders
worldwide.
He became known as ‘The Father of Blitzkrieg’.
His loyalty to Germany was undisputed, but
his support of Hitler and Nazi leadership
was not so clear cut.
He was in fact one of the very few Generals
who dared shouting back at the Fuhrer and
even disobey his orders.
Please join me today for the story of General
Heinz Guderian.
Some clarifications on Blitzkrieg tactics
Before we dive bomb like a Stuka into Heinz
Guderian’s life, I will bore you with some
military theory, as we need to clarify some
concepts.
Blitzkrieg tactics can be defined as the use
of combined forces of tanks, motorised infantry
and artillery, breaking the opponent’s defences
on a narrow front, bypassing pockets of resistance
and striking deep into enemy territory.
Ground forces are provided close support by
the air force, tasked with bombing key objectives
and establishing local air superiority.
The term ‘blitzkrieg’, was actually coined
by the British press, not by the German high
command, as a means to describe the swift
invasion of Poland in September 1939.
German military would have used the term ‘Bewegungskrieg’,
or “War of movement”, and it is a military
doctrine, rather than a tactic.
A tactic is a method of employing forces in
combat, or the ‘how’ you can win a battle.
Military doctrine is the set of principles
by which Armed Forces are organised.
Doctrine shapes strategies, which are the
plans to achieve victory in a war.
I hope I got that right, if any of you have
served, or are serving in the military, please
feel free to correct me in the comments.
But going back to Bewegungskrieg, this doctrine
had been shaping the German armed forces’
plans since WWI. Heinz Guderian and other
military theorists after him, perfected the
doctrine and took advantage of current technology
to maximise the potential of its theoretical
principles.
So, rather than calling Guderian ‘the father
of Blitzkrieg’, he should be ‘the optimiser
of Bewegungskrieg’.
Not as catchy, I know.
But with that out of the way, let’s begin
with the life of Heinz.
Heinz(el) and Gretel
Heinz Guderian was born on the 7th of June,
1888 in Kulm, Prussia, now in Polish territory.
He came to life into a close-knit family with
a long-standing military tradition.
His father, Friedrich, had been a colonel
in the Prussian, then German army.
Heinz followed his father’s career enthusiastically
and as teenager enlisted in the Principal
Cadet School in Berlin.
He was an ambitious and determined student,
his teachers described him as
'always serious'
Well, not always.
Sometimes he was described as
'very serious'.
Heinz soon gained a useful leadership skill,
that is the ability of speaking very concisely
and clearly to communicate his ideas, and
later his orders.
At will, he could turn his communication style
into one that was cold and hurting.
This made him equally famous and feared at
Cadet School, but not very popular.
It appears he made no friends there, at least
until he graduated and got his first command
post.
In 1907, aged 19, Heinz was sent to join the
Tenth Battalion as 2nd Lieutenant under the
command of his father.
We don’t know if this was by design, but
we do know that Heinz did not take advantage
of the situation to just slouch around.
Friedrich Guderian was a stern leader, both
loved and feared by his soldiers and his family,
and he would not make any favours to his son.
Heinz worked hard and learned a great deal
from his father.
Two years later Heinz Guderian’s unit was
transferred to the Goslar barracks in the
Harz Mountains, one of the most scenic parts
of Germany.
He had some time to go horse riding, hunting
and socialising, and so he met and fell in
love with Margarete Goerne, whom he nicknamed
Gretel.
Gretel was the perfect companion for Heinz,
as she shared and supported his ambitious
outlook on life.
They would marry in 1913, and Heinz later
described her as the perfect soldier’s wife:
she could be cool and sensible when needed,
most of all she was able to calm his husband
when seized by frequent fits of anger.
Very often in his later life Guderian’s
hot temper got him into trouble for lashing
out at subalterns and superiors alike.
On many occasions he had to be saved from
disciplinary measures by a superior who appreciated
his exceptional military ability, despite
a poor impulse control.
Later in life Guderian took snap decisions
to disobey orders from above.
He clearly had a talent for leading, he just
couldn’t be bothered with following.
Schnelle Heinz
The year before his wedding, 1912, Heinz wanted
to broaden his technical training and so he
transferred to the Third Telegraph Battalion.
Here he studied hard to become a specialist
in the new radio-signal equipment.
Already at this stage, he saw communications
as a decisive element for military victory.
His studies were not limited to radio: he
studied military strategy, French and English,
so he could study military theory text books
in those languages.
His efforts were noticed, and Heinz was offered
to join a class of 168 officers to attend
a three-year program at the War Academy in
Berlin.
He was moving fast, so much so that he earned
the nickname ‘Schnelle Heinz’, or ‘Quick
Heinz’.
Although he did not see himself as necessarily
‘quick’.
Heinz did not like to rush mindlessly into
action, often quoting a line by military leader
Helmuth von Moltke:
"First reckon, then risk,"
Heinz Guderian's studies were interrupted
when two gunshots rang out in Sarajevo on
the 28th of June 1914: the assassination of
Archduke Franz Ferdinand of Austria-Hungary
led to the outbreak of World War I in a matter
of weeks.
With his radio qualification, Guderian joined
the wireless communication staff.
In November of 1914, he was promoted to 1st
Lieutenant and only one year later to Captain.
His work allowed him to witness almost every
front of the war, including the disaster on
the Marne and the slaughter of Verdun.
The carnage he viewed may have influenced
his thoughts on developing mechanized warfare
to protect the infantrymen and achieve quick
victory.
He never had the chance to command a fighting
unit, but his radio station sometimes came
under attack and he had to fight his way out.
As a result, he was awarded the Iron Cross
second and first class.
In early 1918, he was tested at an advanced
officer training programme, where he showed
the ability for solving tactical problems
with unusual actions.
This impressed his instructors, which accepted
his request to join the General Staff of the
Army High Command.
It is evident how the WWI experiences shaped
Guderian’s thoughts on Bewegungskrieg and
how to improve it.
His post in charge of radio communications
taught him the importance of the wireless,
especially when it came to coordinating the
movements of separate across infantry, artillery
or cavalry.
Although not directly involved, Guderian studied
the tactics employed by the Stosstruppen,
also known as ‘Shock troops’ or ‘Storm
troopers’.
These units we usually successful in infiltrating
weak spots of enemy trenches to encircle,
capture or destroy command centres.
But their successes were short-lived because
of the limitations of, well, just being human.
The extent of the advance of shock troops
was limited by how fast and how far they could
walk before succumbing to exhaustion.
In many cases, capturing a well-stocked British
or French position would mean failure, as
shock troops just sat down to eat.
Guderian’s theories proposed to solve these
limits by supporting infantry with mechanized
and motorised units.
They would require in turn the integration
and coordination of separate arms at the lowest
unit level, in mutually supportive functions.
In lay terms – if you have a platoon of
infantry - 30-50 men - fighting alongside
a tank platoon – 4 or 6 tanks – and they
support each other, it is easier for them
to cooperate, rather than having a whole division
of 15,000 foot soldiers on one side, and a
division of tanks on the other.
Again, my military friends, correct me if
I am wrong.
War of Movement 2.0[TA1]
When the war ended in German defeat, the Treaty
of Versailles allowed the Country to maintain
only a small army of 100,000 troops, with
no tanks nor aircraft.
Post-war, Guderian served as an instructor,
teaching tactics and military history.
It was during these years that he expanded,
developed and perfected his take on the ideal
War of Movement.
He would digest the works on mechanized warfare
of British theorists Captain Liddell Hart
and Major-General Fuller.
He began publishing articles in military journals
and won a reputation for clear thinking on
controversial matters.
In 1927, he was promoted to the rank of Major.
His role was at the head of the Command for
all motorized transport units, and he also
taught transport tactics at the Berlin military
academy.
Basically, his units were tasked with logistics
and transport, not actual combat.
But this did not prevent him from taking advantage
and play around with his trucks.
He equipped some of these vehicles with wooden
turrets, armed with guns, and he moved them
around a training ground as fighting units.
His superiors were not happy and put an end
to his experiments.
But what he could not learn at home, he would
learn abroad.
In 1929, Guderian travelled to Sweden, where
he visited a tank battalion, then to Kazan,
Russia.
Here he visited a secret tank testing facility
co-developed by the Weimar Republic and the
Soviet Government.
Probably he met Soviet tank commanders who
would later become his deadly enemies.
By 1933, when the National Socialist Party
rose to power, Heinz was Colonel Guderian.
Guderian continued with his articles about
armoured and motorized warfare and helped
with solving technical problems of the first
Panzer specimens.
Guderian’ s theories would find fertile
ground with the Nazis and their rearmament
policies.
In early 1934, Guderian organised a demonstration
of Panzer tactics for Hitler.
He later recalled
“The Chancellor was much taken by the speed
and precision of movement of our units and
said repeatedly ‘That’s what I need’!”
Hitler was ecstatic and would provide support
to Guderian’ s innovation, even though the
two men often clashed in spectacular shouting
matches.
Nazi leadership proceeded to re-install conscription,
thus ignoring the treaty of Versailles.
Hitler himself authorized another violation
of the treaty, that is the creation of three
Panzer Divisions.
Guderian was made the Commander of the 2nd
Panzer Division and shortly after was promoted
to Major General, then Lieutenant General
in charge of the XVI Army-Corps.
In 1938 Guderian’s units were the spearhead
of the Anschluss with Austria and the invasion
of the Sudetenland, the German-speaking region
of Czechoslovakia.
These were the years of Appeasement, so the
guns on his tanks were still silent.
A few months later, Guderian was promoted
to Commander in Chief of all the Fast Troops,
or Schnellen Truppen – the perfect job for
Schnelle Heinz!
He was now in charge for the recruitment,
training, tactics and technique of all motorized
and armoured units.
A great leader and poor follower, now Guderian
would be able to bring the full weight of
his studies, doctrine and personality to the
German Panzer Divisions.
He could finally formalise and implement his
take on the Bewegungskrieg.
Which is:
Nr one!
Attacks should be led by large concentrated
number of tanks.
Tanks should not be dispersed amongst other
units, like it was common practice in the
British and French armies at that time.
As Guderian put it:
“You hit somebody with your fist and not
with your fingers spread”
Nr two!
The infantry, transported by trucks and half-tracks,
should closely follow the tank platoons to
support them.
This involves maintaining the logistics train,
occupying positions, taking prisoners, neutralising
anti-tank weapons.
Nr three!
Aircraft and artillery are intended to support
both tanks and infantry, by striking at enemy
armour and fortifications from above and from
afar.
Nr four!
The units involved require a reliable means
of communication.
That involves connecting tanks via radio transmitters
for coordinated joint action.
To generate public support for the Bewegungskrieg,
Guderian wrote and published his first book:
‘Achtung!
Panzer!’
That’s how you pronounce it by the way.
It’s not just “Achtung, Panzer”.
It’s “Achtung!!”
“Panzer!!!!”[TA2]
The book became a military bestseller, essential
reading for any officer.
This book cemented Guderian’s reputation
as ‘Father of the Blitzkrieg’.
Although it should be stressed again that
these were not original ideas – he simply
had perfected and formalised concepts borrowed
by German and foreign military strategists.
An obscure French officer, a certain Charles
De Gaulle, was already a proponent of mechanized
war of movement in the 1920s, inspired by
Polish officer Sikorski.
But in the end, what counts is not who theorises,
but who puts things into practice.
In the book, Guderian summed up this thinking:
"Deeds are more important than words.
The goddess of battle will crown only the
most daring with laurels."
Bewegungskrieg in practice
In September 1939 Schnelle Heinz was able
to put his words into action, during the aggression
of Poland.
Guderian was assigned the XIX Corps, consisting
of one panzer division and two motorized infantry
divisions which he led in an impressive drive
against Polish defences.
But the real revolutionary actions took place
during the Battle of France in the following
year, when the Wehrmacht concentrated their
armoured division and Luftwaffe at the Schwerpunkt,
or “main point of effort,” achieving a
decisive breakthrough against the Allies.
The original plan for the invasion of France
was a repeat of the Schlieffen plan used in
World War I: a quick attack through Belgium
into Northern France.
But Hitler was not convinced:
“You won’t get away with an operation
like that twice running”
Hitler demanded a new approach, based on secrecy
and surprise.
The result was Operation Sickle Cut, devised
by General Von Manstein and Guderian.
The idea was to lure French and British forces
into Belgium and Holland by launching decoy
attacks there, while the main thrust would
be advancing through the Ardennes forest,
considered too thickly wooded for tank operations.
The success of this plan depended on concentration
and coordination.
The French had more and better tanks than
the Germans, but their use was ruled by an
outdated doctrine: they were thinly dispersed
along the front and few had radios.
Von Manstein instead had amassed 7 armoured
divisions at the spearhead of the Ardennes
offensive.
Guderian, in charge of three divisions, was
ordered to cross the River Meuse at Sedan,
where the Prussians had defeated Napoleon
III in 1870.
The day of the offensive arrived: 10th of
May 1940.
Everything went as planned?
Not really.
The German divisions in the Low Lands, did
manage to lure and pin down the Allies, but
the swift drive through the Ardennes soon
turned into a massive traffic jam.
Allied aircraft could have easily destroyed
the German column, but the Luftwaffe did its
job and protected them from the air.
The traffic cleared and Guderian reached the
Meuse one day earlier than planned.
On the 13th of May, he had infantry and engineers
cross the river in inflatable rafts, so they
could neutralize French bunkers and build
pontoon bridges for the tanks.
By nightfall, the defenders were routed.
The French counterattacked the next morning,
but Guderian, leading from the front, had
made the snap decision to set up a defensive
line with artillery.
High command ordered him to wait for reinforcements,
but Guderian disobeyed and pushed ahead.
Between May the 15th and 17th, Guderian repulsed
armoured French attacks in Stonne and Montcornet,
although it was not easy.
Amongst his opponents, Brigadier General Charles
de Gaulle, who almost managed to capture Guderian.
As he remembered:
“His tanks succeeded in penetrating to within
a mile of my advanced headquarters”
This was Guderian’s masterpiece, Operation
Sickle Cut was a success beyond expectations.
This appeared too good to be true to High
Command, which may explain their later cautioun.
By the 24th of May, the bulk of the British
Expeditionary Force was encircled at Dunkirk.
An easy prey.
But General Von Rundstedt, Guderian’s immediate
superior feared an allied pincer movement
and ordered that his panzers stopped 10 miles
from Dunkirk.
Guderian was allowed to proceed only on the
26th.
By then, the French had strengthened their
defences around the Dunkirk pocket, allowing
for the evacuation of the British.
This surely frustrated Guderian.
But, overall, his campaign was a success,
resulting in French surrender in June.
The Revenge of Reality
Emboldened by the victories brought on by
the War of Movement, Hitler started drawing
plans to invade the Soviet Union.
Operation Barbarossa was launched in June
1941, and Schnelle Heinz was again to the
fore.
The campaign was nightmarish.
As we now know, the Army units were followed
by the SS Einsatzgruppen, specially dedicated
to rounding up, deporting and murdering millions
of Jews, Roma and other targeted groups in
Soviet territory.
Guderian was leading Panzergruppe nr 2, heading
towards Moscow in late 1941.
Had he been involved in such atrocities?
Or was he at least aware?
Evidence suggests that Guderian was not an
anti-Semite.
Possibly he knew that Jews and other so-called
‘undesirables’ were sent to concentration
camps for a life of hardships.
And for sure, he knew that his panzers had
been built by slave labourers from occupied
nations.
But it may be that he didn't know about the
systematic killings.
Even his wife Gretel, a stronger admirer of
Hitler’s than Guderian, later was shocked
by learning of the truth behind the camps.
Both were convinced that Himmler and the SS
were the only responsible, not Hitler.
If he somehow had no knowledge of the death
squads, Guderian surely had realised by this
time that Hitler was not a leader he could
follow blindly.
As the Fuhrer imposed ill-judged decisions
on his Generals, Guderian was frustrated by
the lack of criticism.
As the Russian campaign hardened, he wrote
to his wife:
“Everybody is scared of the Führer and
nobody dares say anything!”
As Autumn and Winter set on, Guderian’s
panzers stalled in the mud and snow, harassed
by an increasingly stiff Russian resistance.
One of his most famous quotes is
“There are no desperate situations, there
are only desperate people!”
And yet the situation would prove desperate
even to him.
“We have severely underestimated the Russians,
the extent of the country and the treachery
of the climate.
This is the revenge of reality.”
In December of 1941, Guderian defied an order
from Hitler to advance on Moscow, and instead
pulled back his Panzergruppe 100 miles from
the capital.
This insubordination cost him his job.
Hitler forced Guderian to retire, but rewarded
him with a farm in Prussia.
Countryside life did not sit well with Guderian,
apparently: during this period a pre-existing
heart condition worsened.
But he had no time to properly recuperate:
he was soon to be recalled into service.
Back
in action[TA3]
In 1943 the situation for the Axis was worsening
and the military convinced Hitler that Guderian
was needed.
Hitler agreed and recalled Guderian from retirement,
appointing him Inspector General of Panzer
forces.
This did not appease his temper, though, and
his shouting matches with the Fuhrer resumed.
In summer of 1943 he had argued to contain
Soviet counter-attacks by a strategy of dynamic
mobile defence.
This would imply engaging the Red Army in
a series of local clashes to defeat them in
detail and delay their advance.
The strategy was a contradiction of his beloved
Bewegungskrieg, but it just shows how he had
realised that this was not a ‘silver bullet’
suitable to all theatres of war.
Hitler did not listen to his advice, preferring
the proposal of General Zeitzler: concentrate
almost all German armoured divisions in Kursk,
to defeat the Soviets in one decisive battle.
The Battle of Kursk raged on from the 4th
to the 12th of July 1943.
It was a close call, with heavy losses on
both sides.
But in the end the Soviets prevailed, and
from then on, the War on the Eastern Front
became one of retreats for the Germans.
The following year, after yet another suspension
for insubordination, Guderian was approached
by the circle of Colonel Von Stauffenberg,
who were plotting to assassinate Hitler.
Guderian refused to participate, although
he did not report the conspirators, nor he
warned the Fuhrer.
The failed assassination took place on the
20th of July 1944, followed by a purge of
military leadership.
Ironically, now Guderian was one of the few
remaining leaders that Hitler could trust
for the war effort.
The Fuhrer appointed Guderian as new Army
Chief of Staff.
Guderian's main focus now was to defend Germany
from the impending Soviet counter-attack and
occupation.
He knew very well that the war could not be
won but intended to resist as long as possible.
The main hindrance to his plans, was the meddling
Fuhrer himself.
The quick one finally stops
In March 1945, he was vocally opposing Hitler
in Staff meetings.
Hitler decided to get rid of Guderian and
ordered him to take six weeks of sick leave.
The order was meant to hurt him, ironically
it may have saved him.
Berlin would be surrounded by the Red Army
the following month, while Heinz and Gretel
were in a cardiology hospital in Munich.
This is where US forces captured Guderian
on the 10th of May 1945.
The fifth anniversary of Operation Sickle
Cut.
Guderian was sent to Nuremberg, but not put
immediately on trial.
The Russians wanted to charge him with war
crimes, but the Western Allies didn't comply.
In 1946, Guderian was imprisoned in the POW
camps of Allendorf and Neustadt.
During his captivity, Allied military tried
to evaluate the extent of his involvement
in Nazi war crimes.
As he did not cooperate in interrogations,
they placed him in confinement with two other
Generals, Geyr and Leeb, and wiretapped the
cell.
Even them he kept his cards close to his chest.
This is the only conversation in which he
admits his support of party policies:
Geyr: "Any objective observer will admit that
National Socialism raised the social status
of the worker, and in some respects even his
standard of living as long as that was possible."
Leeb: "This is one of the great achievements
of National Socialism.
The excesses of National Socialism were in
the first and final analysis due to the warped
personality of the Fuhrer"
Guderian: "The fundamental principles were
fine."[TA4]
It was not enough to charge him and Guderian
was released on his 60th birthday
[7th of June 1948]
In the following years he contributed to the
organisation of the Bundeswehr, the armed
forces of West Germany.
He returned to writing, drafting his memoirs
and more military theory works.
His autobiography ‘Panzer Leader’, also
known as ‘Memoirs of a soldier’ was published
in 1952, becoming an international best seller.
Soon after its publication, Guderian's health
failed.
He died in Schwangau bei Fussen on the 14th
of May, 1954, the anniversary of his victory
on the Meuse.
A critical look[TA5]
So far I have told you the most widely accepted
version of Guderian’s life story, the official
version for many decades after his death.
However in the year 2000s, Guderian’s career
and legacy have come under scrutiny from several
historians, such as Russell Hart, Marcel Stein
or Pier Paolo Battistelli.
These authors claim that Guderian’s military
capabilities were undeniable, although he
greatly exaggerated them through his writings.
Hart for example claims that his victories
always came from a position of strength and
numerical superiority, never from a position
of weakness.
While Battistelli argues that his true genius
was as author and publicist of his own image
as the mastermind behind the blitzkrieg, or
bewegungskrieg.
It can be argued that being in a position
of strength is a sign of skill, too, as it
requires planning and preparation.
And that autobiographies naturally tend to
be embellished accounts.
Other arguments are more disturbing, though.
Guderian always portrayed himself as distanced
from Nazi excesses, and as a fair combatant.
Yet, Marcel Stein writes that Guderian’s
units in Russia actively executed under his
orders the infamous ‘Commissar Orders’.
This was the summary execution of war prisoners
suspected to be Political Commissars or actively
representing Bolshevik ideology.
And that, is a war crime that would not have
been forgiven at the Nuremberg trials.
Hart also claims that during the July 1944
coup against Hitler, Guderian opportunistically
played both sides, ready to join the winner
to get a promotion as Chief of Staff.
As acting Chief of Staff, on the 29th of July,
Guderian issued an order forcing all officers
to become members of the Nazi Party, implying
that he was closer to Nazi ideology that he
would have us believe.
I will leave the final judgement to you, in
the comments.
Heinz Guderian: a military genius loyal to
his Country, or a self-serving opportunistic
Nazi?